it's often said that no one can ever
really say what a good relationship is
let alone draw up a checklist for a
prospective one we politely disagree
one pick someone you feel profoundly
grateful ever decided to look your way
start from a sense that you are the
lucky one and that they are superior
the truth in this matter is irrelevant
two make sure you fancy them check out
that you have compatible areas of
perversion and little interest being
normal in bed
three allow yourselves both to admit
from an early stage that you are mad
heavily distorted by your pasts unable
to understand yourselves prone to
irrational assumptions and unsteady in
your assessments of reality
4. make apology the most regular of
occurrences say sorry about everything
all the time and reduce the price of an
admission to almost zero
five remove all Pride from your
character you were an idiot then you are
an idiot now you will be an idiot
tomorrow there is simply no other option
for a human being make jokes
six regularly explore how you've
disappointed one another let them
sometimes hate you and you them don't be
frightened by anger moderately expressed
the enemy of Love is stifled emotion not
maturely explored authenticity
listen very carefully when they tell you
how they feel
seven never describe them categorically
as this or that insulting trait only
ever say I feel you are this or that
observe the difference
eight get good at sensing the fear
beneath your angry moods then Express
the fear gently rather than acting out
the anger
9. reduce expectations of perfection
it's going to be horrible at times allow
for major frustrations you will want to
kill them and they're you
don't
10. except you will have crushes on
others let these crushes wash over you
and if the mood is right share them
gently with your partner
11. if there are children recognize that
love will suffer hugely look forward to
properly picking up the Baton again in
about 15 years
12. become the sort of person who has no
embarrassment about being needy a cept
the child in you and look after their
needs in the relationship
13. read up about attachment Theory and
keep the concepts close at hand at all
times
14. stop being defensive stop needing to
maintain a proud hold on your own
dignity laugh continually your
foolishness and apologize for it 15.
except they can't save you from your own
disturbances try to be happy in yourself
and if you are not don't redirect the
blame observe how often your Rocky
patches are really projected versions of
your own life crises
get a therapist
16. don't expect everything from Love
17 be very prepared The Reluctant to
leave remain always out of choice never
desperation